hey kids by our house anymore I don't
shoot a panic stay calm
okay run run
[Music]
once I miss musket oh it's food what
else is back here oh it's really dark
wait wait what's going on this again how
many times do I have to tell you I will
never leave you okay just hold on tight
I don't want us to get separated okay
here we go
is he not coming is he scared should I
be scared I guess that's it goodbye
forever okay follow me let's smell
everything going don't be scared I'll
protect you
please don't eat her please don't kill
her okay okay don't hurt her take me
take me it's it please please me inside
please please think I blacked out back
there what happened oh oh these things
are unpredictable just wag your tail and
act excited okay this is actually kind
of nice Oh a little more oh yeah that's
nice
and we're done okay we're going this way
we made it home and we're alive and
that's sillier and that and that and you
my second favorite person oh here we go
this is good oh excuse me
where you going where'd you go you know
I can't eat unless you're watching
that's better
just stay there the whole time
why this is the worst moment of my life
ooh is this food no I knew right away
definitely not food I'm getting out of
here
seriously I am very disappointed in you
don't make me go back in there I don't
understand I'm just gonna go back inside
okay bye I feel ridiculous totally
ridiculous
I gotta get dry huh wha huh that's
better
careful don't slip the floor is wet ooh
I just need that can I get that can you
save me that thing oh this is working
ah this isn't so bad this is actually
kind of nice
let's just never do that again deal